philippe douste-blazy douste-blazy
pardon médecin ancien ministre de la
santé
bonjour philippe douste-blazy merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous cet après midi
sur rt france alors on ne connaît pas
toujours on ne sait pas toujours si la
chloroquine associé à un antibiotique
est efficace pourquoi appelez vous à son
utilisation dès les premiers symptômes
parce que nous avons maintenant certains
signes qui nous font dire que l'on ne
peut pas attendre d'abord nous vivons un
gramme sanitaire sans précédent dans
notre pays
ensuite parce que il n'y a pratiquement
plus de lits de réanimation libre c'est
une guerre le président de la république
l'a dit et donc il est absolument
nécessaire si vous voulez d'agir nous
avons d'un côté le père le professeur
awa qui nous montre dans sonné avec son
équipe qui n'y a plus de charge virale
au bout de cinq jours chez les patients
qui ne sont donc plus contagieux et qui
d'autre part s'améliore considérablement
et non pas de complication nous avons
l'agent du médicament américaine
exit aide à plus dure la plus sévère la
plus exigeante qui au vu de ces
résultats
accepte que tous les médecins
hospitaliers américain puisse en donner
à leurs patients dans des formes qui ne
sont pas justement sévère car quand
c'est sévère lyderic taureau qui ne
marche pas enfin on a le taux de
mortalité à marseille lam où le
professeur harold traite ses passions
très rapidement décrit sont positifs
le taux de mortalité à marseille le plus
bas de très loin de tout le territoire
national
donc tout ça mis bout à bout associé à
une étude chinoise qui montre avec un
groupe contrôle qui ne prenez pas les
trucs si chloroquine qu'il y avait
une amélioration majeure de la pop idol
cycloclean oui avec beaucoup de médecins
avec des grands professeurs de médecine
qui appartiennent à l'académie nationale
de france de médecine des âmes ont fait
une pétition s'appelle change.org slash
ne perdant plus de temps change.org slaj
ne perdant plus de temps pour que les
françaises et les français nous elle à
ce que dans les hôpitaux les médecins
puissent donner silver des ce genre de
médicaments car sinon nous n'avons rien
nous sommes dépourvus
nous ne pouvons rien dans une assez
patient et avait-on deux décident de
casser de recycler rockit comme un
poison nous en donnons depuis 50 ans
faisons un électorat de g avant surtout
dit à tout le monde de ne jamais faire
de l'auto médication que des psl savent
ce qu'il faut qu'ils puissent prescrire
ce médicament fiim nous tomasi à votre
avis pourquoi le gouvernement n'ouvre
pas encore justement la prescription
chloroquine à ceux qui en ont les
symptômes
je ne le sais pas je suis confiant que
ce jeune ministre de la santé pied plus
compétents ok mais ça demande aux
sociétés savantes mais ce qui est vrai
si vous voulez c'est que on a jamais vu
non plus aussi une crise comme celle là
il est donc extrêmement difficile de
mobiliser c'est une guerre donc dans une
guerre il faut modifier il faut bouger
il faut changer si on attend l'essai
clinique parfait et je sais qu'il n'ya
pas d'essai clinique parfait je le sais
et je comprends très bien certains
scientifiques y sont des chercheurs
eurent qui désigne à l'epad et c'est
henning parfait donc on ne peut rien
faire mais non justement je pense que
l'essai clinique par faire on l'aura
mais dans quinze jours
dans un mois dans un mois et demi mais
il arrivera beaucoup de fautes a
beaucoup trop de personnes donc
regardons encore le taux de mortalité à
marseille et je pense ça devrait bouger
les choses mais pas n'oubliez pas que
italie en espagne en iran maintenant en
afrique aux mamans au sénégal tous ceux
qui s'en servent sont en train de dire
il y à une modification au total et même
en italie récemment tous les médecins
disaient que hull à la courbe qui est en
train de s'inverser en partie d'après
eux mais ce n'est pas une étude
scientifique est dû aussi à
l'utilisation des drones si chloroquine
à forte chez beaucoup de patients à
philippe douste-blazy qu'en est il des
personnes à risque qu'ils ne sont pas
contaminés
est ce que vous êtes pour une
prescription préventive
le fait de prendre de la chloroquine
préventivement quand on a par exemple
des problèmes cardiovasculaires l'arrêt
dutil la nocivité du coc vide en cas
d'infection alors je suis totalement
contre
cela parce que là par contre personne
n'a jamais travaillé le dessus et donc
en termes de prévention moi je ne ferais
pas autant je prendrai une plaque et 10
de l'hydraulique eurokin si c'était
autorisé si j'avais decaux vide
autant je le donnerai à ma famille si
j'avais locaux vides après avoir fait
d'un tel drame
bien sûr mais là en prévention non et
surtout non plus pas à l'automédication
on ne doit pas prendre ce genre de
médicament qui est un médicament
extrêmement efficace et donc puissant et
comme tout médicament bien sûr dangereux
sur le prend sans prescription médicale
vous parlez de l'automédication qu'est
ce que pourrait entraîner ce genre de
pratiquer l'automédication c'est que
vous pouvez prendre un médicament alors
que par exemple vous avez une
contre-indication vous prenez par
exemple pas médicaments comme le
seroplex eh bien vous ne pouvez pas le
prendre de haut niveau de sécurité il
votre médecin le cw
vous ne le savez pas vous pouvez avoir
de manque de potassium dans le sens où
vous ne le savez pas mais votre médecin
je sais vous mêmes de rythme
le groupe du leem cardiaque vous ne
savez pas obligatoirement remettre ça le
sait donc attention attention pas
d'automédication et puis surtout les
doses
il ne faut pas dépasser certaines
n'osent donc pas d'automédication et pas
de ce médicament prévention vous parliez
tout à l'heure de la france de de pas
mal de choses
qu'est ce qui pourrait faire changer le
gouvernement justement d'avis vous
parlez des six cliniques mais est ce
qu'on peut penser que la france et que
le ministère de la santé pourrait
aujourd'hui changé d'avis sur cette
chloroquine avant un test avec l'unique
parfait comme vous le disiez tout à
l'heure je ne sais pas je sais que
actuellement et des beaucoup d'essais
cliniques sont faits le seul problème
c'est que l'essai clinique discovery par
exemple on sait qu'au départ que l'essai
clinique discovery donnera des résultats
négatifs pour les 36 chloroquine puisque
par définition les drogues si
chloroquine ne fonctionne pas chez les
gens qui ont deux ou en pâtit seibert
avec l'insuffisance respiratoire
or c'est ça les cds ce qu'aubry ces
données et leurs obscurs hockey à
certains et pas d'autres
mais ils sont tous en réanimation donc
ça c'est évidemment ennuyeux parce que
ce test de cet essai clinique de ce taux
réduit
je veux dire ce qui est important aussi
aujourd'hui c'est que nous n'arrivons
pas à faire face à l'afflux de malades
dans les hôpitaux et donc si vous voulez
désengorger les hôpitaux des halles
c'est de permettre à ces patients
atteints de communes 19 qui sont en
début de symptôme de justement prendre
les 36 chloroquine à ceux associés à la
lettre mais si prescrit par un médecin
et après tout cas de g parce qu'il y
aura autant de patients comme ça qui ne
reprend pas l'hôpital et a parlé de roxy
chloroquine
est ce que vous savez aujourd'hui le
ministère de la santé travaille sur un
autre traitement
bien sûr il y à des essais cliniques qui
sont faits avec d'autres traitements de
laquelle on met aussi beaucoup d'espoirs
comme le même désir d'aider des
médicaments que l'on connaît qui sommes
environ des environs avec des
associations également d'anti 0 dont on
verra les résultats
la seule différence c'est que nous
n'avons pas de recul sur ses médicaments
alors que nous avons un recul de plus de
50 ans voire 60 ans avec la nivaquine et
il sachant que les cycles rocking ce
sont des deux tout petits par rapport à
l'année des crimes et des centaines de
millions de gens ont pris une année
victimes chaque fois qu'ils sont allés
au en afrique pendant très longtemps
parce que c'est un antipaludéen et
j'ajoute qu'il ne coûte rien donc là
aussi c'est important imaginait clown
est un drama d'afrique
on serait quand même très heureux de
pouvoir pour donner un médicament qui ne
coûte rien parce que tout ça a un coût
évidemment et c'est extrêmement cher
réfléchissons je sais que ce n'est pas
parfait il ya le remède miracle
les essais cliniques sont tout à fait
encore imparfait mais on voit qu'il ya
une équipe voir des équipes
la franchise en france et bientôt en
italie qui montre quand même il ya un
début d'espoir sur ces ce médicament
l'hydroxyde chloroquine associé à la
vitre homicide après prescription
médicale merci beaucoup philippe
douste-blazy d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir répondu à nos questions cet
après midi je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de santé publique et
d'épidémiologie et ancien ministre de la
santé merci beaucoup